[музика]
[оплески]
яблучний спадкоємство
трампу
засідок дуального почту
про педагогічне світло ранку
ще сам етимології хлопці ж за нурі
вчися в реальний світ розумни процес
моїх можна міс ви виразите загинув там
іноді ще дихнути
[музика]
кадровик дідовичі dp антонів пичу мою
гордість , мтс кого закраїну
you пишайся в тому шум і дав вчення
давай на дні програми президента
рахунок розвитку авіа будемо мною і грузії та
піт римський рожевих по проксі
технічного світи України не фпн ще
таки мідіями і такий позов вібрацію
держава україна і збувається і будуть
слова україна
[музика]
scarlett улю приємно вразив своїм
знанням розуміємо організаційно
технічних проблем, які стоять
варіаційною промисловістю тому той
що він сьогодні вдруге відвідав і в
нас з ним була тривала бесіда щодо
питанню підготовки не тільки робітників
професій а
інженерно-технічні робітники
інженерно-технічної я ми самі питанні
року турки технологу
металургів інші стали туристами
інженерів ось зварювальнику ці спеціальні
зараз дуже великий дефіцит та міністр
скарлетт запевнений, що він особливо візьме
під контроль
підготовку таких спеціалістів
[музика]